in thailand's fields convicted criminals
are tending to a precious crop
they're harvesting green churetta
a traditional herbal medicine
now playing a central part in the
country's fight against covid19
in jail for drugs
the pills this prisoner is now helping
to make have been used to treat more
than sixty nine thousand offenders
infected with coronavirus
the plant is dried and ground
the green powder is then packed into
capsules before being shipped to nearby
prisons
in a trial of 11 800 inmates with mild
symptoms the government claims around 99
percent
recovered
what started as an emergency response to
covid19 is now a key weapon in thai
prisons fight against the virus
more than 140 jails across the country
are now planning to make 38 million
tablets of green terretta by november
china jail is one of those using the
remedy on mild infections
one of more than 700 inmates treated
with it here agreed to speak to me
anonymously
foreign
[Applause]
often overcrowded and cramped
kovid 19 has spread rapidly in
thailand's jails
around a quarter of prisoners have
tested positive in six months
already widely used in thai homes green
chireta is a cheap available remedy
which medics here say helps speed up
recovery in mild cases
um
the thai government's cleared green
charetta for use in asymptomatic
patients it's also being trialled in
some hospitals
[Music]
but this isn't a silver bullet to cure
the world of covid
it's only recommended to help in mild
cases and critics say more testing is
needed to prove its efficacy
but in thailand
this traditional green pill has a new
role in a modern pandemic
siobhan robbins sky news thailand